let's go next to Felix from Torrance
Felix from Torrance welcome to the David
packman show what's on your mind today
how you doing David doing hey I got a
question I got a question please
um I I see more and more of these um GOP
what they've done and what we all know
is they they have tackled and they have
they have taken social media by storm
basically compared to any Democratic
representative do you think this this at
least one Democrat that will start you
know going on Twitter and I know they
feel them do but they they don't do it
as aggressive as the GOP does Felix I
don't know that I know what you're
talking about who who on the right are
you taught you so let's let's see if I
can ask just ask a few questions are you
talking about Twitter specifically right
now
yeah mostly Twitter correct okay because
like the modular greens and and all
these and like even Matt Gates I mean we
uh when we when we see these these um
YouTube channels all they do is show
their Twitter accounts they all these
shows what they wrote and what they said
right when do you think that there'll
ever be like a democratic superstar that
just starts I mean AOC is probably as
close as I've seen yeah AOC is good for
media I mean Felix one of the things
that you're kind of getting to is this
is a structural disadvantage for the
left and it's the following disadvantage
the rights overly simplistic ideas
lend themselves to social media and
short form communication
significantly more than the left's ideas
and think about you know if you're on
the right you can say
taxes are theft it's my money let us
keep it right the left doesn't have an
equivalent because we on the left
believe listen we would all like to pay
less but if we're going to have an
organized and well-functioning Society
we do need to centralize some aspects
through government and the way we do
that is through taxation which one of
those two ideas Felix lends itself
better to Twitter it's obvious it's the
shorter one right
correct so I think that this is
something that has been a challenge for
the left for a very long time I don't
think it's an insurmountable problem I
think we on the left need to be better
at that sort of pithy short form
communication but I don't think you're
wrong I do think for now the right
certainly is it's it's a near Monopoly
in some of these formats
thank you very much Dave my pleasure
yeah take care all right Felix from
Torrance of great to hear from you uh
let's take a quick break and the show
will continue right after this